hey guys dr. Burke here in this short
video I want to talk about calcium
magnesium so let's talk about the
function first of all calcium yes we
know it's for your bones it's for your
teeth but really it's for the muscles
the nervous system and mainly cellular
communication it's one of the main
minerals that helps the cells
communicate okay and so many people have
either too much calcium or not enough
okay if you have too much calcium you
have soft tissue calcium you have heel
spurs kidney stones tartar on the teeth
hardening of the arteries you're going
to get blood pressure that goes up
you're going to get stiffness in the
joints you're going to get arthritis
bursitis tendinitis all the itis and
that's coming from too much calcium now
if you did not take enough magnesium
with it the calcium will build up in the
body that's why you should always take
it together so for someone to take just
straight calcium I would never recommend
that okay so because you need magnesium
to help mobilize and make calcium
function so it controls the muscle the
nerve function even blood clotting as
well so magnesium on the other hand
helps the muscles relax helps the nerves
transmit especially in the heart if
you're deficient in magnesium you'll
typically have arrhythmias atrial fib
and problems with the nervous system in
relationship to connection with with the
muscle itself it's a central nervous
system brain relaxer okay so it's great
for sleeping so now in order to absorb
these two minerals you need vitamin D C
people are associated by Dan in D
absorption with just calcium but you
magnesium needs it just as much as
calcium so what is vitamin D do it helps
absorb calcium magnesium by 20 X in
these in the small intestines so it
absorbs it and it brings it up into the
blood and by the way as a side note when
you're deficient in vitamin d3 you can
get nosebleeds and you can have
excessive bleeding of the menstruation
like the menstrual cycle
so just realize one of the remedies to
help heavy bleeding or nosebleeds is
take some vitamin d3 you can get it from
the Sun or just take it as a supplement
okay so that's what vitamin D does it
helps to transport these minerals and up
into the blood but you also need to go
further into the bones right and to do
that you need another vitamin called
vitamin k2 okay vitamin k2 is a fat
soluble vitamin so vitamin d3 so vitamin
k2 is different than vitamin k1 it
transports calcium from the joints from
the arteries into the bone so if you
have soft tissue calcium buildup it
could be that your magnesium is fine
it's just that you need vitamin k2 so
how do you become k2 division well just
avoid all fats because vitamin k2 is in
all the grass-fed butter in animal
products okay it's also in a vegetarian
product called NATO which is a fermented
soy make sure you get non-gmo but the
point is that vitamin k2 is essential in
the full transportation of these two
minerals into the right place okay so we
need we need these two in a certain
balance we need these two in the body
but we also need this last thing right
here which is an acidified stomach so
many people as they age if they have
heartburn GERD constipation they have an
alkaline stomach it's too alkaline they
need an acidic stomach to be able to
absorb these minerals so if you have
heartburn for example or indigestion we
know your stomach doesn't have enough
acid and that valve won't close so if
the valve won't close the acid comes up
so if you have a nice enough of strong
acid in your stomach the valve closes
and everything is cool but if you have
that problem that means you don't have
enough acid so you can't mobilize these
minerals and they don't really get
absorbed so what you have to do is take
some upside of vinegar pills or the
actual apple cider vinegar and some
water drink with a straw and start to
acidify the body to pull these minerals
into the tissues okay
now what are the ratios calcium
magnesium number one you know people say
well you need two to one ratio too much
too
- two times as much calcium as magnesium
well I disagree because so many people
that I've come across they have I
already have too much calcium they're
like they have their stiffness they have
joint issues they have Spurs they have
all sorts of calcium issues we dumped
more calcium into the body we're going
to have a problem unless they have
osteoporosis if they bas prosess I might
do a two to one but everyone else I
would do 1:1 ratio
why because not very many people get
enough magnesium because they don't have
enough leafy greens that's where you get
it from all the vegetable family you get
calcium from broccoli and other things
but realize that broccoli and even kale
have they're a little bit higher in
oxalates so sometimes that might block
the absorption of calcium so an even
spinach as well so that's why you need
the lemon juice I have that in the other
video so there's a I don't want to
confuse you but here's the point I like
to get my calcium from a little dairy so
maybe there are some grass fed you know
cheese or something like that a little
bit each day and you have enough calcium
so I don't like to take too much calcium
but if you're going to take it take a
small amount one-to-one ratio and you
can take more of it if you're doing some
program or detox or you know you have
osteoporosis or you're maybe you're
trying to sleep or get rid of a cramp in
your calf which that's an indication
that you need this but the point is that
I want you to understand that there's a
lot of different factors involved in the
balancing of these two minerals the
absorption of these two minerals from
the stomach having the stomach pH it's
not just a matter of oh I'm going to
take this vitamin because someone told
me to take it you have to think with it
and take it when you need it and so
you're not taking too much alright so I
just wanted to kind of review all that
I'll put some notes below and definitely
continue to watch my videos and make
comments below I'll see in the next
video